In this summing numbers problem, we're given a string
such as the one I have here, "hello 2 all of you 44."
And we output the sum of all the integer numbers in the string.
So here we have 2 and 44,
and we're going to return the number 2 + 44,
and with some advanced math, is 46.
How are we going to solve this?
Well, one way, using only the totals you had in CS101,
might be to iterate through the string character by character,
checking if the current character is a number
and then continue concatenating that string of numbers
until we don't reach a number, so we'd have 2, and then we'd hit a space,
and then we add 2 to our total running sum.
That isn't a very elegant way to do that.
We'd rather use regular expressions to help us out,
so to get us there, let's think of a regular expression
that matches the numbers that we are looking for.
Well, numbers range 0-9,
and we want 1 or more of them, and that's it.
We're going to use our friend re.findall with this regular expression
in the input string, and for everything that's matched,
we add it to our running sum.
Let's write a bit of code to do just that.
I remember to import the re library, and I've defined
my procedure sumnums that takes in 1 parameter that is the sentence.
I've now written the regular expression that we came up with previously,
and I initialize my sum to 0.
And now I'm going to run find all with this regular expression
on the input sentence, and it's going to return a list of all the occurrences
of that regular expression, in this case, a list of all the numbers.
So found is going to equal one at a time
all the numbers found in our input sentence,
and remember from the hint given in the problem,
the int procedure will turn a string
into an integer if it so applies,
and so we're going to update our sum with the integers that we find in the string,
and once we're done, we're going to return the sum.